[Música]
hablábamos ahora de revistas de prensa
con los haberes más de burros a hoy ya
viernes y abrimos revista de prensa como
lo hemos venido haciendo desde que
empezó esta invasión rusa hace ya 16
días atrás se ha pasado muy rápido
cuéntenos entonces y vamos a comentar la
portada de nuevo de the economics la
estabilización de rusia
buenos días raúl exactamente esta
portada es muy clara no no sé si ya la
estamos viendo pero además utiliza esta
seta de apoyo a las tropas rusas que
comentábamos pues hace unos días en esta
misma selección y lo que viene a decir
este artículo no que responde a la
portada de este medio británico es que
cuando putin ordenó la invasión de
ucrania él soñaba con reestablecer el
imperio ruso y que lo que ha acabado
reestableciendo es el terror pues
ejercido por josef stalin y que dice que
pues se está convirtiendo putin en un
dictador en rusia recurriendo como nunca
antes a mentiras violencia y para brutal
esta fruta a mí me encantan rosa y vamos
a una información de la agencia noticias
reuters facebook habría cambiado su
política y permitiría discursos
discursos del odio contra rusia lo vemos
en público exacto una vez más la
moderación de los contenidos en las
plataformas digitales particularmente en
aquellas que son propiedad de meta de
facebook puedes estar en el centro de la
polémica porque sabemos que lo que se
publican en facebook lo que nosotros
publicamos en estas plataformas pasa por
una moderación de contenido y por una
filtración que elimina teóricamente las
publicaciones que son explícitas
contenido explícito de violencia o
apelaciones a la violencia no y sin
embargo me está según una exclusiva de
la agencia reuters firmada por music
venga til y elisabeth clean ford
estaría suspendiendo o no esta política
de moderación ahora en el contexto de
ucrania por lo que permite pues alabar
incluso pues al batallón neonazi de asof
o llamar a la muerte de vladimir putin o
también del presidente
de la rusa alexandr lukashenko según ha
expresado meta en un comunicado hace
permite esto para que las personas
puedan expresar sus sentimientos en el
contexto de la invasión rusa y puedan
pues desahogarse contra los invasores
diciendo por ejemplo muerte a los
invasores esta suspensión también se
aplica en territorio ruso pero ya el
fiscal general ha pedido al regulador de
telecomunicaciones que restrinja el
acceso a instagram y también pues ha
considerado meta como una organización
extremista vamos a ver lo que dará de sí
toda esta situación así es rosa vamos
ahora a ver qué está tirando la prensa
independiente rusa pero limitada por
estas nuevas restricciones del kremlin
que encontramos en el mosquito de nóvaya
gazeta pues de moscú tenemos básicamente
raúl destaca que ya 250 compañías
habrían roto lazos comerciales con rusia
según un estudio de yale y que la crisis
económica podría ser mayor que en los
años 90 por otro lado también pues
encontramos el nóvaya gazeta que como
hemos señalado aquí en ocasiones pues
pidió al tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos que digamos pidiera a rusia que
permitiera a los periodistas
independientes pues continuar ejerciendo
su derecho su derecho a informar a la
población sin embargo pues éstas esta
sentencia que ha sacado el tribunal
europeo de derechos humanos no tiene por
qué ser cumplida por viernes de viñetas
como ilustran la situación actual venia
ginseng the gardian y coco en liberation
exactamente aquí vemos pues por un lado
en liberación a los dirigentes de la
unión europea pues agarrados no a este
gasoducto que va hacia rusia y nadie de
ellos pues se atreve a empezar a
cerrarlo no dicen quién empieza
podríamos pasar del gas ruso pues a ver
quién da el primer paso en europa porque
pues sabemos esta situación de
dependencia es una de las claves no de
la posición de europa en este conflicto
y por otro lado en el medio the gardian
ven james pues digamos dibuja a vladimir
putin como una cigüeña y en lugar de
estar llevando bebé se lleva a ver es a
raíz del bombardeo en ese hospital
maternal cambiamos de tema porque la
prensa chilena se centra hoy en la
investidura de gabriel boric el
presidente de chile que fue elegido en
los comicios del pasado diciembre rosa
que está con la tercera y el
desconcierto pues la tercera por un lado
como vemos aquí dice que el gobierno de
gabriel boric anuncia el retiro de 139
querellas por la ley de seguridad pues
que se impusieron a contra manifestantes
durante el estallido social de chile de
2019 para que no se use esta ley para
perseguir la protesta política y por
otro lado el desconcierto hace un último
balance de las promesas incumplidas del
gobierno de sebastián piñera rosa nos
queda ya poco tiempo pero por favor
vamos a repasar la prensa de corea del
sur como registraron los medios de
comunicación esta es como cómo iban
avanzando las elecciones presidenciales
pues es raúl lo hemos querido destacar
porque digamos es una forma de presentar
los resultados muy distinta a la que
estamos acostumbrados acostumbrados aquí
y la hemos conocido gracias al
periodista andrew penn que la compartió
pues en twitter aquí lo estamos viendo
cómo van compartiendo pues son imágenes
sobre todo que corresponden a la
seguridad casting company pero también a
otros medios de comunicación surcoreanos
y vemos aquí como los dos contrincantes
pues digamos se enfrentan en distintos
escenarios que parecen más sacados pues
de un videojuego o de una película
digamos de aventuras ya que no de una un
programa de noticias que explica los
resultados electorales en todo caso pues
cualquier estrategia es buena no para
digamos informar a la población mientras
sea de forma contrastada
así es rosa gracias entonces por toda la
información de esta revista de prensa
nos vemos el lunes con más pasamos ahora
a hablar con eso primer invitado el día